yacht au monde c'est vous le savez déjà
aujourd'hui on se retrouve pour la suite
d'aller désolation c'est parti on venait
donc de prendre le métro parisien arrêt
châtelet les halles il me semble on
continue sauvegarde familiale alors on
peut monter des marches ou alors on peut
aussi monter des marches bâche propose
tout le monde et marche alors c'est
parfait je me demande ce qui nous attend
là y allait y aller casier qui sont
apparus déjà j'augmente sous parce que
s'il vous plaît on veut de la frayeur à
à droite une petite salle porte fermée
nickel là bas est ce que c'est fermé
les armes ne sont pas autorisés ici-bas
écoutait déjà si je trouve une armée je
passerai cohen
je vous rassure à attendre mais
qu'est-ce qui va pas et que ce truc tu
vas marché à la fin prendre l'ascenseur
vers 6h communication salut oh [ __ ]
mais y'a personne mon gars j'ai bien
compris qu est ce que j'ai fait je me
bats je peux pas la torche à plasma
routier ce qu'est ce qu'une torche à
plasma je sais pas attention seules
glissant très utile convient d'aller
dans le vé souhait d'une meuf qui doit
me tirer dessus mais bon en fait je
pouvais aller juste tout droit à danser
la sainte odile heures d'accès elle
essayé de pirater la sécurité de la
société ayant grillé mais ça que grillé
c'est du gâteau
ok dit quelles nouvelles cellules de
données je trouve ça ou pas n'y a
vraiment aucun problème
ok alors tu as raison je propose qu'on
lui a trouvé qu'on la butte non non non
non un [ __ ]
non ok on est cachette à mais c'est
horrible ce même pas là lien qui nous
poursuit ses des humains [ __ ] c'est
affreux alors là c'est juste là en rien
des chaussures bonne diagonale donc ce
point d'exclamation ctspec en fait je
suis sûr qu'il va venir la regarder
mesdames et mesdames et messieurs si la
porte de votre côté mais c'est super dur
sur déconner regardez regardez on se
retrouve et donc non je recule à la
temps je suis caché dans la canopée qui
vaut très cher chichon where is luca
luca idier non thibault sécurité trop
élevé luc eyes in the who is in the
movies jusqu'au cou c'est un bon moment
pour décédé tu vois à l'été juste là
elle a volé mon cartable à la dre mais
en fait je peux taper les gens si
j'arrive par derrière en fait je peux
les défoncer mais attendez qui fait pas
confiance cette loi confère tout va bien
se passer
non
ilan est devenu mon faut qu'ils me
voyaient ensuite je cours un c'est le
seul truc à faire mais ya pas de
journaux où se cacher je pense qu'il
faut que quand il ouvre la porte badge
et défonce mais la dina a oui là il m'a
vu je crois hélas ils arrivent pas un
bruit
by deux pour le prix d'un caissier de la
dans votre inde mais mes tympans ce
matin profite qu est ce que tu peux
prendre le gain de poids qu'elle ait ex
de gan please the gun s'il vous plaît
chercher mais du cher mais c'est plus un
truc c'est parce que ses membres à
l'estec [ __ ] il est où je vois pas
aller là bas mais il vient c'est bon ils
arrivent when you're gonna do what
you're gonna do wah la fox biche
alors qu'est-ce qu'il avait nui [ __ ]
encore un mais ça ne s'arrête jamais
netanyahu
il va venir et bien
enfin c'est mieux alors il vient ou pas
ça bien
j'ai cru que j'allais mourir à cause de
toi tu t'en fous que tu sois mort alors
qu'est ce que tu as un mode car notre
mission dévolue vers elle me dis pas que
tu as encore un fond déconner quoi on va
pas tous se faire toute la colonie bla
bla bla bla bla bla non il ya des bruits
c'est moi il ya des bruits ses multiples
[ __ ] mais il fait des frayeurs au
regard des lovebugs écouter le bruit ok
bon endroit mais j'ai peur qu'il reste
un mec là une balle on décède et sur 17
vautours faire sauvegarde s'il vous
plaît aulas et par là je crois oui mon
gars oui
y at il une sauvegarde je cherche une
sauvegarde actuellement je cherche ni un
mec une femme dit quoi que ce soit
d'autre juste une [ __ ] de sauvegarde
s'il vous plaît aux
or aux yeux un bruit y aller au bout il
y avait un bruit bombe à l'estac gym est
dans le camp du oui j'y vais dans le
conduit au j'ai trouvé un truc secret
génial ici chercher une issue revolver
camelot fumigènes on reviendra après
j'aimerais trouver un truc pour
sauvegarder en fait le temps presse pour
se cacher non ya pas besoin
auj qu'est ce ça fait du bien
beachy c'est aussi ça fait du bien au
monde y en a un en plus on va avoir
plein d'amis tous soient ramassés sur
les mecs juste avant bobitch ok j'ai
juste à sortir lieu des gammes comme ça
un peu comme mon agent me débrouille il
ya des bruits c'est toi qui fais ces
bruits [ __ ] de demain ne fait même pas
vivre au revoir alors la question
aulas ben amos a comme l on semble fons
mon gars si un ennemi mon gars ont le
défonce comme ça y at il quelqu'un ou
quelque chose qui sait ô ô merde tu
attends j'ai vu une cage juste avant
voilà camelot de kaamelott
oh merde mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé
mon gars c'est un bon sang qu'est ce qui
était arrivé à huy trois balles ou alors
c'est vrai que c'est plutôt la queue de
la lienne je pense schéma grenades
aveuglantes ça me plaît ça objets
fabriqués
voilà elle est là elle est dans ma main
elle est très belle très mignonne est ce
qu'on peut y aller la niveau de sécurité
trop élevé bah oui bah bien sûr c'est
qu'il s'en étonne vraiment est ce que
quelqu'un est étonné bombes fumigènes v1
ou
il ya des schémas en fait qu'on ramasse
pour kraft et des choses c'est sa
munition de revolver et on n'est pas
dans la 16ème édition de revolver après
j'espère que les mecs marimba sinon on
va vite vite être déçu ni ponsero
on va enfin pouvoir savoir ce qui est
arrivé aux vaisseaux de notre maman moi
qui suis un battant un écart moins
important au nom au nom fichiers
corrompus c'est comme les cartes sd
bah oui top tu as bien raison non ça
sert à rien ça c'est comme les pc ça
sert à rien à part leur pays tri
concentre toi
ah oui d'accord ok ça marche nickel on a
gâché une balle
or nous en sommes voilà il va bouger
très bien je dois faire ça et tout c'est
ça
ramasser les cellules de données oui
bitches un synthétiseur dax est en
marche
1 et ben voilà donc on a accès au port
de sécurité de niveau un pirate et
l'ascenseur vers 6h communication faut
que je parte pour ça donc logiquement je
peux sortir à tort
non j'ai réussi voilà c'est bon oui
c'était moins une
ok j'ai compris comment ça marche super
s'il ya quelqu'un ici faire que je ne
rigole pas oh oh [ __ ] je restais un
mec assez bien mec mais décidé à bafou
que je retourne là où il y avait la
fille en fait à wil sauvegarde
j'en ai marre bah moi aussi j'en ai
marre désactiver le bureau de sécurité
j'y vais de ce pas y avait un medikits
au oui yes un plan pour faire un médikid
voilà au plat la piquouse qui ressource
un peu à peu le dire mais bien un truc à
faire là voilà
au désactive le verrou de sécurité au
bord de touche quand elle a appuyé sur
des cubes c'était bon olaya nadine qui
arrive ya là les caries et on le voit
pour le voir faire tirer dessus tiens là
dessus le volley-ball vert non non pitié
pitié de cinématiques mais redonne pas
la main cette grande que vont tous deux
non il est reparti la bâtie
[Musique]
juste là juste là etc royaume ou
revolver c'est comme si je vous envie de
la patafix de m on fait quoi alors on
fait quoi alors il est reparti pour
croire que ouais tandem essai il faut
pourtant à l'ascenseur qui étaient dans
la salle du tout des loups garous
il est passé par où la lienne hockey
agents temporaires ou y passent tous
passent pas la réput un tu ne nous aura
pas d'après mon gps fait maison 1 c'est
ça c'est là qu'on doit aller à les
descendre hockey aa je remonte bâtard je
ne suis pas serein donc vous ne l'êtes
utilisés sur twitter terme depuis quand
ils brouillent et cette porte
çà çà çà allait aux montois oui peut
aller plus vite [ __ ] 1 alalalala c'est
ton bien sonores
o o
vous l'avez vu vous l'avez vu autant que
moi
vous l'avez vu comme moi voire même plus
que moi or face quoi la sanction est
juste en bas là l'ascenseur est juste en
dessous nous il est là office de
l'office de je pense pas que je peux
ainsi que lui un falloir qu'on attende
toi non non non jagger moi je te défonce
monga tiers dans le crâne dans le cochon
allez allez allez allez allez ouvre-toi
will travers elle c'est au tour d'italie
ok c'est bon c'est bon
ah ah ah ah ah ah tu crois que tu m'as
fait peur non mais vraiment mais simuler
et tous pour la vidéo quoi de me
regardez pas comme ça c'était très
éprouvant comme situation savait pas de
quoi il est capable ce [ __ ] aliens on
arrive dans un nouveau venez là oh là là
oui on est ou alors est bien sûr et
passe par là et la porte est fermée des
erreurs comme d'habitude j'ai envie de
vous dire oh merde oui bonjour mon nom
et replay un mandat replay j'ai besoin
de votre aide
d'accord je m'assois ou je te tiens dans
le ventre donné un nom mais la lie en
brouille la la ça sent pakula vous voyez
bien le mec est qu'à la manche où voyant
des lots je m'assois où il a pris un
sèche-cheveux union non hélas il n'y a
eu ni l'un ni l'autre
kim prend en charge la à mais regardez
on au milieu d'eux mais il reste que des
gens comme ça c'est obligé qui nous
veulent du mal mon gars c'est clair et
net
rd le lui ai fait je dois aller au
contrôle des communications c'est urgent
d'accord portant vous voyez pas ce qui
se passe bah ouais on contrôle la
situation
justement est presque terminée laissez
tomber
je me trouverai un jeu n'en a pas
écoutés
tétouan jungle moi fils de chien chat
ingrate choqué tous malades et crutchlow
station depuis le début un pape
puissance faible il faudrait que je vous
montre la puissance de sa agents
collants mais qu'est ce que tu peux
encore la [ __ ] y'a pas un truc pour
sauvegarder juste derrière là un jour et
rêver voir sa moto en ag le détecteur si
cette optique liesse
il a été trafiquée et alors c'est tout
aussi bien tu vas pas me dire que mon
détecteur est ok on which is an
maintenant et se passe pas du tout n'ont
eu que j'installe un verrou manuel sur
la porte qui mène à l'état je ne veux
aucun accident je sais ce qu'on découvre
ce qui cloche très bien moqué un truc
qui cloche
accès à la porte forcée le mécanisme de
la porte oui ah ben voilà enfin et puis
tu as l'âge fait des va et vient et je
ne trouve pas alors donc c'est par là
que ce qui se passe ici est ce qu'on va
devenir meilleur pote avec l'allié année
enfin en liesse au oui mais voilà
j'attendais que ça donc le verrou manuel
c'est celui-là qui l'installé ce qu'ils
disaient et alors qu'est ce qui a des
recettes porte-voix bientôt le savoir en
tout cas et bah absolument rien mon gars
y'a rien du tout et une salle avec de la
pommade
c'est très bien un raté un petit peu la
peau puisque c'est vrai que l'espace ce
cas méritant un plan émetteurs de son os
je vais pouvoir attirer des ennemis à ça
va être des petites phases
d'infiltration ça je le sens alors
maintenant qu'est ce que je fais au au
salut ça va mais très commence une zone
interdite
oui et donc fait demi tour laissez-moi
pas si les six mois passés sur contacté
mon fils
oui laisse moi faire
vous êtes désormais connectée à apollo
il connaît mon nom et mon prénom sur la
station sébastopol ben c'est très bien
et oui un autre chemin 1 je lui trouve
un autre chemin bitches peaches ta
chance que cette visite soit fait en
sucre ouais bah voilà l'agencé dia fin
de cette quatrième vidéo sur aliens
isolation j'espère c'est vous a plu ces
gars comme d'habitude n'hésitez pas aimé
la vidéo
là je sens que les choses commencent à
se compliquer on a vu la lienne on a vu
les android qui ont l'air normal et un
peu méchant et met fin à la fois je
pense qu'ils sont carrément pas normal
en fait humblement on valoir dans les
prochains épisodes j'espère que cette
série vous plaît vraiment et on se
retrouve vite dans une nouvelle vidéo
chat au monde
pis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]